these health workers say making people
aware of the spread of Cholera is the
best way to keep them safe in The
District of mwamba they're going door to
door telling people that drinking water
may be infected and should be boiled
before use
we do door-to-door visits we talk about
sanitation and explain to them how to
use soap and how to keep the water clean
for consumption by giving them chlorine
the community are adhering to it very
well
many homes in this rural area don't have
running water
people collect water from a river to use
for drinking bathing and cleaning
the water is untreated
we feel the water but we don't have any
other way here in wamba there is a
shortage of water the population around
here uses water we know that there is
cholera but we don't have any
alternative we use it for drinking
cooking and washing
foreign
agencies are working to assess and treat
water sources but haven't reached all
the affected areas along with the
government they're vaccinating people in
the worst affected regions
this is kilimani a Seaport where
authorities say the number of cases of
Cholera has arisen alarmingly it's
worsened after Cyclone Freddie
devastated the area last month impacting
Health Services the government plans to
distribute 2 million vaccines this year
and is immediately targeting more than
400 000 people cholera is a water-borne
disease and contagious it causes severe
dehydration vomiting and other symptoms
and many hear or worry that if cases
continue to rise small Health Facilities
like this one won't be able to keep up
Mozambique